hey this is presh talwalkar
in january 2018 lady karen brady posted
a maths puzzle on twitter with the
challenge to solve it in three minutes
after people gave their replies she then
posted the correct answer and
congratulated people who got it
but as a twist piers morgan tried to
correct her
as it turned out piers morgan is the one
who was wrong
he used his calculator to verify and
then jokingly said he got the wrong
answer because he was unaware about
baudemus and the order of operations
well piers morgan if you don't know
about bodmus and the order of operations
you need to watch mind your decisions
videos you'll learn all about them and
you'll get the correct answer to all of
these puzzles
the daily mail even covered the ordeal
and obviously i need to cover more
puzzles like this so more people can
learn about the order of operations and
how to solve these problems
so what was this puzzle she posted
it was the following mathematical
equation
so you have three minutes to figure it
out
when you're ready keep watching the
video for a solution
so there are two details you have to pay
attention to
in the third line
the equation involves three dog bones at
a time
and in the very last line there are just
two dog bones
secondly the very last line involves a
multiplication
so you have to remember to multiply and
you also have to remember the order of
operations that multiplication takes
precedence before addition
so now let's solve this problem
the first equation is that three
bulldogs equal fifteen
so that would mean we divide by three
and we get a single bulldog is equal to
5.
in the next equation we can use the
value of 5 for the bulldog and then
solve for the value of the two black and
white dots
so we have five plus two black and white
dogs is equal to thirteen
this means two black and white dogs are
equal to eight
so one black and white dog is equal to
four
next we have the equation that a black
and white dog plus a total of six dog
bones is equal to ten
so we have the value of four for the
black and white dog
we then have six dog bones and that's
equal to ten
this means six dog bones are equal to
six so a single dog bone is equal to one
we can now use the values of each of
these variables to get the correct
answer
so we have the black and white dog plus
two dog bones multiplied by the value of
the bulldog
so this will be four plus two
multiplied by five
so what does that equal
well piers morgan incorrectly did
the quantity four plus two times five he
just went from left to right and he got
six times five which is equal to thirty
this is the incorrect answer because
you're supposed to use the order of
operations according to pemdas or bodmus
you need to do multiplication before
addition
so in that case we need to do 2 times 5
first so we have 4 plus 10
and that gets us to the correct answer
of 14.
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
linked in the video description and you
can support me on patreon
if you have a math topic or puzzle you
can email me presh mindyourdecisions.com
or you can catch me on social media
either at mind your decisions or at
presh talwalkar